[Musique]
en tant que chef de fil de l'action
sociale le département de La Réunion
s'est tenu aux côtés d'Agnès Firmin le
Bodo ce samedi 24 septembre pour ce
dernier jour de visite la ministre
délégué chargé de l'organisation
territoriale et des professions de santé
accompagné notamment du président Cyril
Melchior et du préfet Jérôme philippini
a rendu visite aux résidents de la
Maison Pierre Lagourgue à Sainte-Marie
l'accès à la santé des personnes vivant
avec un handicap était au cœur de cette
rencontre nous avons des personnes des
associations des groupements qui se sont
engagés au peuple aux côtés des
collectivités pour accompagner les
publics les plus fragiles
et le département
prend pleinement sympa comme vous le
savez au titre de ces compétences en
matière d'accompagnement des personnes
en situation de handicap à travers
notamment le transport scolaire adapté
l'attribution des allocations de
solidarité l'aide dans l'amélioration de
l'habitat ou encore le soutien des
aidants
et ici il y a d'innovation et bien le
département porte la création de son
propre CFA des métiers d'aide à la
personne en ce que comme j'ai eu
l'occasion pour le diable rapidement
mais on aura l'occasion d'en reparler
c'est vrai que en matière de formation
des personnels et bien nous devons aller
beaucoup plus loin la visite de ce foyer
d'accueil médicalisé rattaché à la page
l'association pour adulte et jeune
handicapés c'est achevé avec la
signature de la charte Romain Jacob le
Président vous avez parlé
et vous avez très justement dit que la
Réunion est un territoire d'innovation
sociale que ce que je vois depuis hier
on fait dire que oui vous avez raison et
c'est bien le terme qui convient la
Réunion est une vraie terre d'innovation
sociale cette journée de rencontre avec
les acteurs de la santé c'est poursuivi
à la maison de santé
pluriprofessionnelle s'acquis soigne de
la possession une structure pensée pour
faciliter l'accès aux soins de ville
pour les
[Musique]